can i ask you a question uh we revealed
big news
on the podcast which is that you are
pregnant
with twins yeah and
you you talked about it on the podcast
has anyone
heard about it through the podcast who
who didn't know in your immediate circle
or did you manage to get to everyone
first because i would think that would
be socially awkward if say your mom
heard it on the podcast
but you hadn't told her or tack yeah or
or you know your husband tech
he's driving on the freeway listening to
the [ __ ] catching up
and he drives into a barn
[Laughter]
yeah there were a few people we forgot
to tell and that's how we found out they
texted us and they're like
you're pregnant with twins
and you didn't tell us well this is a
good way to find out who listens to the
podcast
i know who really listens well and also
i mean they listen because they're
they're my friends and they care about
me also i guess they're
fans of conan whatever yeah let's get
some i'm sorry
let's do a quick correction there
they can call you anytime but if they
want the pure
liquid comedy gold they've got to come
to the fountain
of said gold conan o'brien uh and you
play a part you're there with your ladle
and um and gorilla you're there with
your little cup to get some of the
liquid gold and splash it around but
this little thimble
a little thimble but uh yeah
that's why your friends are tuning in
you think my friends are tuning in
because of you
instead of me yes
yes i do i i think they can talk to you
anytime
but they're like oh my god is he on that
podcast with you
my god god
and then they listen and then they hear
you too and then they find out that
you're pregnant
and they call it they call you anyway
this is fun brief look into my mind yep
sona how's it all going uh
how's your mom handling this news she
uh has been uh waiting
uh you know i mean i've known you for
many years and for years she wanted you
to get married
yeah i mean to the point where it was
like just anybody you know
okay calm down wasn't that bad it was
just
she you know she was getting a little
restless but she wasn't like anything
you bring home just marry it
you and i did a segment in armenia
where i took you to uh a woman
who matched armenian
men with women did you not yes we did
you seriously considered some of those
men and many of them were no i
didn't they were in their 60s oh my god
they were all like and also i think that
they i think matchmaking is looked down
upon in armenia
and so they had all either gone to
prison yes had like five kids
remember that woman you can probably
look up this segment online but i took
sona to this little house
in armenia in uh and this woman
was showing you people and every time
and she'd show us a picture and it was
um
this guy who maybe was i want to say
conservatively 65 or 70.
and looked like he'd been in a fight and
lost
multiple times and then she would say i
like this guy's good this guy's good now
there is a problem
she would always say there is a problem
we would go what and then they would she
would talk about he was in
prison for what well this is the best
part
we i have followed up and i said
imprisoned for what and she said i can't
remember
he was eating with somebody and they had
an argument and he
stabbed him with his fork
and i'm looking at this guy who looks
like a pirate
long after the ship went down
and he stabbed someone at a meal who was
his
friend so watch what you say
at the wedding dinner to this guy so
anyway no i i
i jest but you married this uh the
perfect guy
yeah i did tack i can never remember his
last name so i just add an easy and to
his first name which is tact tackisian
yes it's which is not his name but yeah
yeah the keysian that's not how armenian
names work you don't just
add an ian at the end of their first
name that's
well they all have an en at the end of
their last name right they they do
but it's not i'm suggesting to the
armenian people lose the middle man just
add an en
to the back of your first name so it's
tactician
so i'd be sonysonian yeah no that's sona
it doesn't make sense i'd be conan
stupid
yeah you could pass for armenian you
could with that complexion
i could be an armenian man who's
very ill
and then i go on that website that that
woman has